hello everyone I hope you are all having
a great Saturday and since I've already
shown you one game that victory by
Fabiano Corwin I do hope you enjoyed
that I promised I'd show you another one
and what better game to show you then
the one where a real opening was played
and by a real opening I mean the
Sicilian and neither so this is a very
interesting game a very interesting line
the two of them played and their score
till this moment in time before this
game was played is actually pretty
pretty equal
they drew eight games night each won two
games and cost someone three games so
only plus one for constant definitely
definitely a strong player as I've
already said the colorful Grandmaster
arca denied each so let's let's check
this game out and as you've seen Bobby
is now in the lead after winning his
game against anvil in the in this round
definitely if Carson wants to keep keep
the pace he he has to do something about
about the game so let's see it
efore we have c5 as I didn't announce
the night off
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and a
six so we have the knight or variation
of the Sicilian and here knowledge goes
for g3 something called the Zagreb
variation of the night off and it was I
saw an interesting article here crossing
played a 5 and Knight to b3 but Janna
Ponyo she used the used this wood white
and there he play Knight to f3 and after
night to h4 it was a very interesting
game that he was against and rebel
kitten in 2016 world blitz championship
in Qatar Doha and he won he won a pretty
cool game but in the game night didn't
go to f3 not Knight goes to B 3 so this
is something differently prepared by
night each bunch of 3/7 Bishop to g2 and
here Carlsen castles we have castles and
Bishop to e6 rook to e1
Knight comes to d7 and here nice to d2
it's a pretty pretty normal position you
would find that when playing against the
Nitro fan you
often have a night on v3 in the knight
on c3 and here
I pretty much have this like in every
game I played against the night off I
always go a 4 since I don't I don't like
allowing b5 I don't wanna you know allow
black any any expansion on unnecessary
but in this game nice 2d - although a4
was a perfectly viable option so costly
me immediately goes b5 as in I did allow
it nice to f1 so the idea of this night
to be 2 is to go to f1 a student find a
nice outpost on e3 and later on to
control d5 and perhaps even have the
option of going f5 Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen f3 and now Fischer
back to e6 93 know this Knight
definitely is on a very nice square root
to see it and now a3 not allowing b4
now we have knife to b6 here maybe maybe
planning some jumps on c4 also
controlling d5 as you all know that
every Sicilian player wants to put that
d5 but it's very rarely possible if
white plays correctly so F for preparing
f5 rook to e8 and first came to h1 you
don't want your king and this dark
square diagonal the immediate f5 doesn't
really give anything it doesn't really
give anything for white simply Bishop to
d7 and now this d5 will be an even
greater threat in the future since this
point is already on f5 and if you don't
gain gain anything by pushing a pawn you
generally don't want to push it too
early or at all
so rook to e8 King to h1 first and now
Bishop to f8 f5 Bishop comes to d7 and
now Queen to d3 h6 as always I useful
move making some breathing room for a
king maybe ideas like in 92 h7 to g5
will be possible in the future
b3 controlling this night on b6 not
allowing him any squares but of the c6
and now Crossing is creating pressure on
this eforp on the right is attacking it
the bishop is attacking it as soon the
Queen will come to b7 - also joining the
attack so better to
Quinta c7.r up to see one further
further protecting the c21 as the Queen
and rook are kind of eyeing it this
night doesn't really have the option of
moving Queen to b7
now with even more pressure on d4 pawn
and now Knight e to d5 Bishop captures
pawn captures and now Knight comes to d7
and now as you can see now the D pawn
and the f1 are much weaker than they
were before before they were pushed so
if you're not gaining anything by
pushing the pawn don't push a pawn nice
to d1 e for now
Queen to d4 and now Knight to e5 and
this is a very deadly idea by Carlsen
Knight to e5 so what happens if if an
idea grabs the pawn so actually a very
subtle idea after Bishop captures Knight
captures you have to capture with the
Queen and after you capture with the
Queen you're kind of getting in line of
this rogue then Knight to c4 is coming
with an attack on the bishop and after
losing the dark square Bishop the black
will have plenty of compensation the
problem is you can't grab with the rook
and this is the real idea if you crab if
you capture with the rook then comes
nice to f3 again with the same idea
attack the Queen and the bishop and
after Queen moves rook captures on c4
now we see the problem Queen captures
Knight captures on d2 and although we
don't win a piece here
Queen to d3 there's nowhere to go with
the night there's the Bishop to e7 and
now you can see that you cannot DeGraff
the night because Bishop to g5 will win
the rook on c1 so first you have to go
h4 and now as you gain the tempo with
this be 7 you also develop your bishop
now you will grab a pawn ruin White's
pawn structure but of course you will
give back the piece after Queen captures
and now you'll have a nicely developed
Bishop on f6 and the black is much
better here
so after this knife the e5 Knight EG
goes for Knights to f2 so keeping it
cool now attacking the e4 pawn with the
knight Knight to f3
now comes up with a wood a fork on the
Queen and the rook Bishop captures pawn
captures and now c4 be kept person c4 b
captures on c4 and now rook to
five attacking the f5 point we have rook
to e3 rook captures Queen captures and
now Queen to be 2/9 to d3 attacking the
Queen Queen Queen comes to be - now
white wasn't able to capture on f3
although that's a very annoying point
because now the Queen is attacking the
bishop here so first you attack the
Queen Queen captures pawn and now you
can capture Queen captures on f3 Queen -
a - again attacking this Bishop on D -
Bishop to c3 attacking the knight on f6
and now first rook captures on c4 so
Carson doesn't mind opening up his King
and even if you capture on f6 there's
still a dark square Bishop there ready
to protect call since King so first rook
to a1 attacking the Queen and when the
Queen moves the ASX pawn is attacked and
since your Bishop is attacked twice now
first Bishop captures on f6 pawn
captures and now it was a here I didn't
catch the live coverage but it's moved
30:37 night is about to make his 38th
move so probably his very long time and
he's trying to reach move 40 and time
control and you know decisions in this
in this stage of the game are crucial
and can very well have a decisive
outcome on the game here Queen to d1 was
was a must move you have to offer a
trade of Queens get your queen out of
the spin as Carson is preparing rock to
c3 and here black would you remove the
Queen or exchange Queens and white could
play on but here King to g2 was played
here Knight each thought I'm gonna find
a nice a nice light Square and it's a
nice safe Square for my king get there
it will be perfectly safe and then I can
continue playing this game and see what
I'm gonna do with the a6 pawn and so on
and so on
but here comes struggle rook to c3
now of course with the double attack on
the knight rook to d1 only movie do you
have to defend it now H 5 H 5 a very
nice move now Knight which finds his
king to h3 move this is more 40 he
reached
time control and here across and reaches
also time control by playing Bishop to
h6 and this
the idea of the h5 move now you can see
what cousins idea was you can't grab the
point if you play Queen captures and
attack the Bishop rook captures on d3 is
perfectly fine
rook capture screen captures and after
Queen captures on h6 Queen captures an
f5 comes with check King moves quick
after Sun d5 and there are simply too
many passed pawns here black wood black
would win this game so after Bishop to
h6
Knight each played rook to e1 he gave up
the night here
but now cousin played rook captures we
have Queen captures on h5 and now rook
to e3 and it was in this position and
move 42 that Arkadiy night which
resigned to the game what if you resign
well for the obvious reason he's done a
piece and there's nothing for him to
play if you play rook captures simply
Queen captures Queen is protecting the
bishop on h6 you can't win back the
piece there's nothing for you to do here
and even if you don't capture it if you
play Queen captures on h6 then rope
captures anyone and okay the white queen
is very close to the black King but
there is no perpetual here of course
Knight it shared this before he resigned
the game you could play let's say after
Queen to f3 the Queen has to come come
closer to be able to defend now after a
couple of checks for example Queen e8
king g7 Queen g5 now King f8 now you no
longer have Queen to d8 because now the
rook can come to eat as the King would
be protecting it so after check on h6
King moves Queen h8 checked into 7 there
are no more checks in the position well
there are checks as you always say I
said there are no more checks but there
actually are there's the Queen e8 Queen
d8 Quincy 8 there are a lot of checks
but not none of the none of them are
useful so this would be kind of
pointless next to black and played
pretty much anything and win the game so
yeah after rook to e3 and I did resign
to the game and a pretty nice win with
the black pieces for Magnus Carlsen
so before I forget it let's check out
the standings after round 7 so here they
are like I said in my previous video in
first place Fabiano Caruana with 5 out
of 7 so that that is
an amazing result in a field like this
where he's playing against the monsters
like like this and even the world
champion magnus carlsen is here so 507
in second place trailing very very near
him magnus carlsen and Nikita with
YouGov still still keeping it in there
in force the 4th place because he lost
his game against Caruana Maxima
sherrilyn Grove and 11 Aragon who won
Greinke chess classic last year so but
you know he's in there
I believe he's playing Caruana our
enemies playing Caruana tomorrow so if
he beats beats him you know anything is
possible again then blue one with three
and a half night each with two and a
half and which two and a half how I
found which two and a half and the gear
Meier in last place with two points so
those were the standings I do hope you
enjoyed that and I would like to thank
James Talmage for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon and an off-topic
announcement I did reach rank 5 in
hearthstone so going for a legend now
thank you all and I will see you soon